ήταν και λίγο πολύ ντάξει ο καατισ δες ήταν μέσα στο λαϊκών στους εργάτης ιδύος
της γερμανίας εκεί ήταν ω στα λιος και σε δεν ήταν όμως ο μήθος στίλιος
που είναι σύμβρα θυμάστε κάτη αναπεριστατικό ιδικά όταν το ανακοινώσατ προς το τέλο στην κατάσταση
το ήταν σοβαρή κατάσταση τη θυμάστε από για την περίο καιταξετε τοτο γνώριζε ο ίδιος
κατανοοσ το καταδυσκολία της και δυσκολίαται το πρόβλημα το κατανογο βέβαια και το ντιμετώπι στο
ϊκά ο ίδιος σα έλεγε δεδεν τοδεμε συζητούσαμε τόσοοι συζητήσεις μας ήταν περισότερος της στην
αδικεία που εσε ο ίδιος στης ζωή του στο στη στων τρόπον της ζωής που
επέλεξε ε τον ένιας καθόλου ύτε η δημουσιότητα ούτε τίποτα διερχόντωσαν υπουργεί για να τον
επισκεφθούν και δεν τους εδέχεται όταν ταν όμως κανέένα παιδί μια φορά α παιδάκι από
ένα εργά τη δεκαξιχρονό μόλι τουτου ίπα ότι είναι να παιδί πογενηθηε στη γερμανία δεκαξι
χρόνον και θέλασεδί αμέσως μολε παρών που ήταν δεν ίνα στην καλύτερη κατάσταση λέ θελοτοδο
και κατ όρες μαζί του και το εδηγήθηκε το παιδά κι πως τον εγνώρισε πως
άχουγε τα τραγούδι για το από τον πατέρα του και υτό διδι έδείχνε τη απλώτηταν
που είχε αυτός ο άνθρωπος ισα στανεκή μέχρι το τέλο έτ ι ήταν στη γερμανία
μετά των είμαστε των επισκεπτόμουν αρκετά συχνά όταν επέστρεψε στην λάδα και ίμον μαζί του
ναι πάμε σθα άλλο θυμα γιτε τεχνιτινοημοσύ σε μερικά χρόνια θεωίτο θα αντικαταστήση τους γιατρούς